da sind wir wieder und es ist gerade
muss ich ihnen sagen wirklich nicht
einfach es ist wirklich nicht einfach
die meisten themen machen wenig freude
ich sage nur corona virus in deutschland
und das so kurz nach karneval so kurz
nach karneval immerhin immerhin noch
läuft es bei uns scheinbar alles
ziemlich geordnet
es gibt krisenstäbe und jedes bundesland
als seinen eigenen epidemie platt was
sinnvoll ist weil viren sich bekannt
nicht streng an landesgrenzen halten
insgesamt insgesamt können wir wirklich
sehr froh sein über unser deutsches
gesundheitssystem ohne ironie da werden
andere auch froh wenn sie das hätten
auch wenn man im kreis heinsberg aktuell
natürlich nicht wohnen möchte auch der
öffentliche personennahverkehr ist
ausgesetzt die ersten supermarkt regale
leer gekauft erlebte das die leute
relativ ruhig sind aber trotzdem sind
alle in panik
ja ruhig aber in panik
fasst die situation ganz gut zusammen
und das kann man niemandem verübeln weil
wir eben noch so wenig wissen über
dieses verdammte virus umso wichtiger
umso wichtiger den leuten immer wieder
gebetsmühlenartig zu sagen was man über
machen kann anderen menschen nicht
direkt ins gesicht niesen und ja hygiene
halt das fängt ja beim händewaschen an
all die mittel hände waschen hände
waschen hände waschen hände
desinfizieren händewaschen händewaschen
händewaschen händewaschen händewaschen
händewaschen oder v
[Applaus]
das feld
da ist also jetzt waschen sich also alle
karnevalisten fleißig die hände
nachdem sie bis aschermittwoch tagelang
anderen besoffenen die zunge in den hals
gesteckt haben lehmann
die man kann man die ausbreitung noch
stoppen und kommen hier auch weil so
quarantänemaßnahmen wie zum beispiel in
diesem innsbrucker hotel das hotel hier
das ist am späten nachmittag kurz nach
17 uhr isoliert worden das heißt die
polizei kontrolliert die ein und
ausgänge
derzeit darf auch niemand hinein oder
heraus beobachten können
und wenn du dich einfach mal ist auf
seinem roller können sich die viren
nicht kriegen
alle experten sagen fast alle experten
sagen es besteht weiter kein grund zur
panik fakt ist allerdings corona wird
zur herausforderung für unsere groko
leider und das ist mal ein fall von
blöden timing leider ist aber die
regierungspartei cdu gerade auf
selbstfindungstrip große frage wer wird
neuer parteichef also unter angela
merkel natürlich in diesem irren
dreikampf den wir gerade erleben märz
laschet oder röttgen ein riesen thema
natürlich auch im karneval in mainz
stürzt ein zwerg namens thüringen die
cdu und ihre vorsitzende in eine tiefe
krise in düsseldorf bringen sich ihre
vier männlichen potenziellen nachfolger
schon in position
[Musik]
es ist eine sehr rätselhafte
installation
warum versteckt sich norbert röttgen in
seinem eigenen sack es ist das muss der
künstler selber wissen dabei
dabei
nicht mal so häufig zu ertragen
sage ich als ostwestfale so aber
verdammt clever ruf jedenfalls vom herrn
laschet sich den jens spahn ins team zu
holen oder also einen gelernten
merkel-kritiker dem armin wird ja immer
unterstellt er sei muttis liebling dabei
freut er armin sich total auf die zeit
nach merkel
und manchmal ist er da fast schon etwas
zu euphorisch wenn es geht die kanzlerin
wird ihr amt beenden und dann beginnen
die 20er jahre dann beginnt eine neue
zeit dann beginnt aufbruch das wird so
super wenn die alte kiste tja da darf
ich muss nur ein lauf bleiben
[Musik]
ich finde immer so süß den arminen dann
habe ich ein bisschen neuen aufbleiben
und zu viel cola trinkt die ich bin
jetzt schon ganz ehrlich laschet und
sparen sind für mich jetzt schon das
beste team mindestens sein batman und
robin
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
laschet und sparen
das dynamische duo der cdu muss
entlaufene wut wähler von der a3 wieder
zurück fangen aber ohne dabei den grünen
haben zu machen er schält und sparen
beenden dass thüringen dilemma der cdu
sie lösen das dumpfe bundesland einfach
auf und geben es den tieren des waldes
zurück und sparen immer bekämpft von
ihrem endgegner den fiesen joker märz
kommt er in seinem privatflugzeug und
sparen die neuen absoluten super chefs
der cdu also unter kanzler wo man
natürlich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da ist natürlich noch nichts entschieden
ich meine klar der herr laschet ist am
besten vernetzt in der cdu und trotzdem
wer weiß vielleicht wird es beim
parteitag am 25
april am ende friedrich merz ja könnte
sein und mit dem als parteichef
da wäre direkt alarm direkt denn ich
glaube kaum dass ein herr merz sich von
seiner erzfeindin merkel reinregieren
lässt da landet die wahrscheinlich
ratzfatz an irgendein autobahn darstellt
irgendwo bei brilon kann ich mir
vorstellen für mich ist merz jahr
inzwischen so was wie der sauerland tram
überlegen sie mal schimpft ständig über
die medien gibt den quereinsteiger aus
der wirtschaft obwohl er eigentlich in
erster linie lobbyist war und findet
sich selbst insgesamt ziemlich geil
also relativ gut kann man sagen und das
obwohl er noch nie irgendeine wahl
gewonnen hat gar keine
dafür hatte aber erfrischend neue und
ungewöhnliche ideen im kampf gegen
rechtsextremismus schließlich daraus
richtig dass ihre antwort auf das
problem des rechtsradikalismus die
stärkere thematisierung von
kleinkriminalität grenzkontrollen und so
weiter ist die antwort ist ja
ja klar verstehe schuld am
rechtsextremismus sind letztlich
ausländer
märz und der uralte masterplan afd
wähler zurückholen indem man sachen sagt
die afg wähler mögen das hat noch nie
funktioniert weil die leute immer das
original wählen aber mach doch ja
vielleicht klappt's ja diesmal und dann
ist da natürlich noch der außenseiter
der renegade norbert röttgen ja übrigens
in der kompletten geschichte der brd
einer von nur zwei bundesministern die
jemals gefeiert wurden alle anderen
dürfen zurücktreten das tut weh das tut
richtig weh vor allem wenn der zweite
rudolf scharping war ja das muss sein
ego erst mal verkauft und dann und dann
muss sich der arme norbert bei seiner
kandidatur pk auch noch solche
komplimente hier anhören
2012 ist relativ viel über ihre
schwächen geredet worden
in zitaten von parteifreunden wenn sie
so nennen wollen sie sein
beratungsresistent sie seien bis zum
autismus irgendwie nicht zugänglich da
war von realitätsverlust die rede also
ist also eigentlich also eigentlich
würde ich jetzt gern nach hause gehen
und weinen der norbert das war nicht in
ordnung wir halten fest ins finale um
den cdu-parteivorsitz gehen also drei
stolze xy chromosomen träger bislang
noch keine frau reden wir drüber mit
unserer betriebs frauenbeauftragten
dörte hausten geschiedene knalligen
dingeldey dörte was kann man sich als
frau von diesem trio erhoffen
ja da darf ich in meiner eigenschaft als
heute schon bachelorette einfach mal
sagen ihr kriegt alle drei einander
keine rose von mir aus nie gleich mal
mit musik eigentlich stehen gehört ja
jetzt mal ganz im ernst die drei tenöre
diejenigen ich und denn wagen die doch
noch eine frauenversteher zu machen
während laschet und sparen ihre
pressekonferenz jedem fällt dem rücken
zu hause of war normal
die haben ja beide einen penis wird es
ihre schwachstelle
da hab ich doch mal raus beschreibt die
zweite person in meinem team mit einer
frau sein und märz ergänzt später im
falle meiner wahl werde ich der partei
in jedem fall eine frau als
generalsekretärin vorschlagen bau einer
frau aber auf rückfrage konnten übrigens
beide nicht sagen welche freude sein
soll
weil sie nämlich überhaupt keine einzige
frau kennen
so wie sie damals als sie sich mit 16
diese freundin ausgedacht haben ja die
angeblich im ausland levers war noch
nicht ausgedacht die michelle die hatte
ich auf der konfirmand fahrt kennen
gelernt ja ist klar machen wir uns
nichts vor die wahrheit ist in berlin
ist das matriarchat offiziell
abgeschafft man könnte auch sagen sa
bassa becken trauen
warum sitzt neben ihnen jetzt keine frau
also die breite dessen was wir als
gesellschaft abbilden müssen muss frauen
enthalten aber am heutigen tag habe ich
jetzt mit jens spahn bald eine lösung
gefunden
sicher wenn man partout keine frau haben
will ist jens spahn vielleicht ohren ort
lösung jedenfalls in armin laschet welt
also zumindest als macho ist der army
mir bisher nicht aufgefallen ja dann
stimmt da hier beginn recht und erstellt
die die weibliche wähler wirklich
interessieren sollte man wäsche noch mit
dem wäschetrockner trocknen oder sollte
man sie nach draußen hängen
keine ahnung wir sind etwas männersachen
eigentlich nie
ich bin ja quasi ein sich selbst
reinigen des ökosystems
also habe ich verstanden sie können in
diesem trio absolut keinen lieblinge
entdecken.de gar nicht nicht
und am schlimmsten ist natürlich dann
märz 19 95 stimmt er gegen die reform
des abtreibungsrechts 97 gegen die
strafbarkeit der vergewaltigung in der
ehe
da hilft auch keine weibliche
generalsekretärin
aber herr welke ich muss ihn ja jetzt
mal nebenbei gesagt waren ganz schlimme
dir stehen neuerdings erotische träume
keine falschen hoffnungen nicht von
jenen nicht von ihm sondern von einem
kanzlerkandidaten
ich fand den früher zum kotzen aber
verglichen mit der cdu flats bieten ist
er in meinen augen einfach nur hot und
bis hin doch nicht verschlechtert sich
einfach von der person ab dem stil also
es gibt männer zaghafte männer
schüchtern der männer so wenig
so hat es mich schon bei schüchtern
markus willst du diese rosa um gottes
willen dörte auswahl darunter thema it
service bruns ich spreche mit jürgen wie
kann ich ihnen weiterhelfen
ja haben sie mal versucht das gerät aus
und wieder einzuschalten hat nichts
gebracht verstehe ja probieren sie doch
mal den kanal der heute show auf youtube
zu abonnieren
genau und im zweifel ruhig auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung